bienvenue au paradis des petits chats
trouver une solution contre la
prolifération de l'errance féline c'est
l'objectif du chat tipi de Marly-le-Roi
ce lieu atypique nous a ouvert ses
portes
[Musique]
Marnie chasse en toi et One Voice se
soutenu par la Ville ont créé de toutes
pièces cet espace pour les chats
sauvages qui ne peuvent pas être adoptés
une fois stérilisés le but est de
maintenir leur protection
[Musique]
vous avez des dodos un petit peu partout
le chalet en fait a complètement été
isolé tout était fait maison par nos
bénévoles au total ce cabanon peut
accueillir une quinzaine de chats qui
évoluent en liberté et pour les plus
craintifs l'extérieur aussi a été
aménagée pour subvenir à leurs besoins
là vous avez aussi un petit espace en
fait pour qu'ils puissent se nourrir
derrière une petite maison voilà pour
s'abriter et là donc vous avez le chalet
et un enclos pour les habituer en fait à
rester sur les lieux après on peut les
lâcher vraiment libre dans la nature
[Musique]
et le chat tipi a déjà ses habitués
comme en témoigne l'album photo de
l'association et les vidéos de
surveillance malgré le développement
déstructures les bénévoles appellent à
la stérilisation pour éviter donc la
prolifération parce que on récupère
énormément énormément de chats non
stérilisés le but c'est d'arrêter la
prolifération il y a trop trop de
malheureux mais surtout il souffre les
chats des Russes sont souvent récupérés
en très mauvais état en 2022 Marly
chasse en toi a pris en charge près de
120 chats cette année 97 chats errants
sont déjà passés par l'association